how do i find the first few investors
and keep them happy in my business yeah
I think it's great question and you know
one of the things when I was in the
start there's this other kind of windy
outside your own bc money and all that
stuff um I think what I would advise
generally if you've got a great business
idea you really believe in it um
probably start if you can do we just
research asst image set of our customers
actually use our own life savings or
remortgage their homes to fund their
businesses I will be advocating if you
can do go friends and family first um
and then you keep control and and you
kind of you know again you can waste a
lot of time go to banks go to finance
houses go to VCS when you should be
building your businesses a lot of your
customers following to drink so I kind
of put more interested in to that but
it's time to go is when you've got
something that you think real tangible
and they'll call it a kind of proven
business model but ultimately then you
kind of have Pierre nails and cash flow
projections and all that sort of stuff
underneath it but the longer you can
defer that I would be a big big advocate
then and the only way that I'd argue
against myself is if you come across
something where you have got the next
Facebook and it's going to be so massive
and so big and you've got to invest at
scale we've gotta go global because you
know you're just gonna miss that when
your opportunity and then my make sense
to go through the fruit and you know
there's a lot of people I'd have a new
note tons of people in candor Toronto
who can actually fund businesses in the
UK in the u.s. angel investors are
probably out advocatus the best route
because again they're not in vases they
won't interfere and they'll give you
capital based on a business plan and
trust and it allows you to get on and
really kind of fun the next day to do
business I hate spending money till I'm
making money just as a general rule I
think anybody can spend money if I give
you a million dollars you can find a
million different ways to spend it not
everybody can make money and so that's
the discipline you need to learn
and when you are out getting investors
the hardest i used to be a VC it was
raising half a million to 15 million
dollars for companies the hardest money
to raise is the startup capital because
it's the riskiest time and they'll take
the biggest chunk of your business right
they could take three percent of your
business for a small amount of money
because there's a high risk where if you
can show them that you can deliver a
result that you can get some revenue
that somebody's willing to actually pay
you for this the easiest kind of money
to raise his expansion capital mean I've
already selling I have some sales come
in and now I need to grow that's easy
money to raise will get a much better
valuation and raising capital can be a
full-time business for you and like
Stephen said that takes your eye off the
ball of actually running your business
and so if I were you I would try as much
as possible to focus on the execution
find little ways to get started invest
my hustle my time my energy not dollars
and especially not other people's
dollars until I got to the point where I
had a product that was out that was
making some money i mean i'd be
profitable yet but i'm making money I
have a path to profitability because it
really reduces the risk and you'll get a
much better deal from investors